[Music]
Zen Dead or Alive news submitted by
cheesecloth a man died for 21 minutes
and came back to life as he was being
transferred to the morgue Oh dead for 21
minutes oh did he see hey soos no well I
mean he might have did he say he didn't
describe it I know I was waiting for
them oh I know I want to heaven stuff
but you know you never hear people being
dead for twenty-one minutes a long time
oh did you hear about like someone going
out for like a minute or two and they're
like oh my god my whole life flashed
before my eyes
but this dude 21 minutes came back
normal
like he's brain everything's all good
yeah so at first I think this is what
happened hmm
his soul went up and in another angel
soul or somebody was like I got a
mission to do anyway in so it's not even
him anymore
angel possession ex yeah yeah it's like
that but yeah he's well that's one of my
favorite movie me - no but everyone
sleeps on that movie oh yeah this is the
[ __ ] I guess Kevin Spacey's not
ruling he's kind of cancelled brain I
don't give up Kevin Spacey was a good
movie in that time maybe he I don't know
he did some crime you didn't do it space
he touched babies right nah it was a
good movie a good premise and they
everything they talked about
scientifically was like oh [ __ ] makes
sense capex still till this day I mean
like Kevin Spacey is still great actor
doesn't take away from his talent yeah
he might be a piece of [ __ ] yeah but
that's all great the art from the art I
already knew artists and musicians and
everyone was batshit crazy my [ __ ]
own [ __ ] parents are that like what
the [ __ ] who's what kind of dumb [ __ ]
thinks that powerful people and creative
people are seen like that's the terrible
terrible mix you're stupid you think
like elementary stupid you know that
know you are but what am I like how are
you shocked that they're crazy yeah I
don't think people are shocked because
there's Korea I think they're shocked
that they're doing some vile acts I
think it was expected no it's not not
that's why that's what it builds my
vibes on that I'm not I'm not vote you
or or yeah we're not saying it's
justifying it
I'm just saying that if you do this you
probably eat Dookie at home you know
there's like in order to create this
kind of person you guys is crazy now
eating Dookie at home and they're not
that far from Tokyo crazy people crazy
eyes as people is the level of crazy
though yeah you know and that's why
we're not that famous deal those guys
are a less yeah do you Robbie Williams
JK art let's go I think we're like
middle-class creative so we're not
genius like some people a good like this
but it goes like this I you never saw
this grad school you like not like
you're joking aside the people that I
have admired that I've met in person
they're [ __ ] you're nuts looking off
you gotta be in order to be that's why I
think I'm not supposed to be Eminem
he'll ruin it for you know yeah it's
probably craziest buck is Eminem gonna
be really angry all the time pretty is
really sweet I so if I ever have an
opportunity I can [ __ ] list yeah but
I don't think I would honestly I'm very
faithful I'm like super like writer dive
was he too old
no he's just become more of like a like
a father figure a big brother rather
than like someone that I see is like
someone I want to [ __ ] yeah oh yeah it's
just transformed because he's been it
part of my life for so long anyway let's
talk about this guy that died so this
guy isn't gloutch Chester Shire I don't
have pronounced that correctly passion
speak if you're in the UK you know what
I'm talking about so his name is I don't
even know how to say his name is like
jao al Rajas Chow you say that Joe
Salazar delicious Wow
Oh 800 like a Brazilian neighbors oh
okay
his eyes rolled in the back of his head
while he was in the car and then his and
she's so sheet like shivered thinking
about it but like this is a sigh maybe
just like it's all good
probably family see cameras here you
know suck my dick in a car no more I'm
here better than I was you guys always
think that
how do people safely do it you cannot
[Laughter]
[Applause]
below pray I'm giving her prayer drink
righteous now she comes and says honored
girl chat alright she can say cut it
she's not dude you don't even know this
Julia she sucked the fake dick on Jake a
party the other day you don't even know
me and we're playing all sorts of fun
games thousand-person I will never ever
go on she did it so she could win the
game and I respect that
I respect that he was challenging me and
I was like Julia would never do this and
she's like oh yeah and I was like damn
how do you know she had it in her
this is what's going on let's continue
this is the story about a guy that died
because eyes rolled back
very complete the story but I couldn't
because Joe kept talking about rodents
so I had to deflect it somehow okay I
just saved that I haven't talked in the
last four minutes okay
maybe thirty seconds but that was all
y'all I felt like four minutes - you
started it you were the catalyst for the
30 seconds like four minutes good Juliet
why you smell like incense like you
smell like the incense section of the
Spencer aisle I don't know what it
smells good good you know the incense
oil I know what you're talking Spencer's
is like your favorite [ __ ] story you
only talk about Spencer's in Walmart
when I go to the mall Spencer's and
Cinnabon I always kind of go to those
times always like Cinnabons always on
top it's so funny he's like I'm having a
me day yeah Cinnabon and beautiful
cinnamon bun Spencer look alright dude
though his eyes roll back in his head
his tongue started getting going into
his throat and his wife was freaking out
so she jammed her phone into his mouth
so he could still breathe wow what is
that you're supposed to do yeah yeah I
watch that's what she thought of like
just try try to get his mouth to stay
open so there's some air going in we're
supposed to stick there back there and
pull the tongue back out or no I don't
know but she didn't do that I would feel
like my fingering like if I'm on their
side
maybe fart in his face by the time the
paramedics arrived
the Portuguese man was suffering a
cardiac arrest so they rushed him to
heart attack they rushed him to the
hospital and doctors treated him using
all the equipment that they could but
after six hours all the shots and
injections were deemed futile and CPR
had been unsuccessful and they
pronounced him dead at approximately
4:00 p.m. on Saturday April 18th 2009
and then his spirit saw his wife cry and
he said nah
I'm coming back because immediately they
called his wife and children and it was
like they phoned his parents and
Portugal his parents were like oh my
gosh he's dead
and then the nurses were transporting
his body towards the mortuary and they
noticed some movement and it had been
2100 freaked the [ __ ] out you'd probably
like he wants to see it goes I bet you
right when that [ __ ] woke up
you've been right there okay so then the
cardiologist was like oh my gosh and
told the family the good news but he
warned them that if a person is dead for
longer than four minutes that there
would be permanent brain damage since
there's no oxygen accessing the brain at
that time he remained in a coma for
three days when he woke up a new
nickname was granted to him by the staff
called miracle man sorry Steve you're
not the miracle man anymore this guy's
the freaking miracle man he likes thinks
he's a miracle man well I see the
miracle man he just calls him himself
the miracle man because he'll be running
like so late and then he'll get there
five minutes late instead of an hour
late and he's like I'm the miracle man
I'm like you're still late [ __ ]
[ __ ] magic he thinks any like old
sleight win and he's like that's why
they call me the miracle man watch
[Laughter]
they had no explanation for how this
could have happened so that's why they
call them the miracle man but after you
woke up they asked him a bunch of simple
questions like his name is age whose
family members were but he gave like
really illogical answers like I don't
want to be on Big Brother like get me
out of here no paparazzi
yeah yeah basically like a computer like
trying to process his brain couldn't
understand like the right things so like
another spirit that was just getting
used to it was a celebrity spirit who's
really confused about why he was in the
hospital he's like I only have a throat
problem what's going on he was just very
confused so they like put him in a step
oh he actually disconnected himself from
everything and went to a separate room
and a shower well cuz he didn't think he
was supposed to be there he was like I'm
su it's in there like if you woke up and
thought you got kidnapped and put in
like Mentalist oh that's a good one yeah
yeah yeah yeah I wouldn't do anything
that makes me appear crazy just pulling
off my [ __ ] thing I wake up I'm like
okay if I'm probably in a mental
institution I can't do anything that
makes me appear crazy excuse me serial
killer do you do man no excuse me and
she would try to be logical but she
would say the wrong words like she would
be try to flirt to try to get out of
something and she'd be like she'd be
like um my clown shoes are dirty sleek
please let me out my uncle had a stroke
recently and this [ __ ]
I know it's funny but this guy is so
[ __ ] dumb like he is so adamant that
he didn't have a stroke and he wouldn't
go to a hospital his base is all [ __ ]
so after he has a stroke they're like
he's talking he's not the hive and I'm
like
and act like five minutes later he gains
his [ __ ] back and he goes I'm fine for
like ten [ __ ] minutes you jackass go
to the [ __ ] Hospital
[ __ ] dumb dude stubborn as [ __ ] no so
he's completely back tonight I have him
for two weeks he like didn't know what
was going on and then you can went
completely back to normal like
everything completely normal doctors
cannot explain what happened be on a
book tour now no he has a defibrillator
in his heart but that wasn't even the
first time that wasn't even the first
time he skipped death in 2005 he had a
crash in Spain which left him it was a
play a crash it doesn't a plane crashed
your car crash but it left him with a
broken femur pelvis four ribs and
shoulder blade he also suffered a 90%
blood loss damaging increase and liver
doctor said he would never survive the
Opera the wife is like please I've been
trying to kill you for years so this
dude he doesn't die stroke was caused by
the previous accident yeah when he died
or when he woke up was his wife like
next to the plant like this he was
getting wheeled into the mortuary when
he woke up oh shoot they even dead for
over 20 minutes anyway is this is this
the longest recorded time those that
somebody's been dead it doesn't say are
you so I've read articles about people
who had been pronounced dead and as
they're getting buried in the coffin
they come up and then they start banging
oh how many people do you think like how
got buried alive we're gonna coffee no
[ __ ] they used to do this thing back in
the day we're gonna get buried they
would have a bell so if you are alive
you could ring the bell and they would
take you back oh my god this guy coming
back to life and he just hears his faint
voice in the distance of his wife
playing [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]